[Applause]
welcome to Alaska I'm just outside of
Fairbanks and I'm trying to find the
Northern Lights the aurora borealis but
the conditions haven't been ideal
because tonight it's a bit cloudy a bit
hazy and we've got a moon out which is
nearly full so it makes it very
difficult to spot these Northern Lights
so what are we actually looking at up
there or the aurora the electromagnetic
fields working through the gravity you
know and the particles that work off of
that what do you have to have happen in
order to get those lights cold you're
going to be looking at solar activities
how to do a silver flares as the flares
are coming up I know it has to be
something with the Sun and discharging
its solar flare the Sun has just put on
quite a show take a look at these
amazing pictures captured by a NASA
spacecraft yesterday it's a powerful
solar flare shooting superheated
particles and plasma deep into space
no one knows what's really going on
those pictures they just look cool so
what sort of stuff is coming from the
Sun um it is oh I believe it's solar
radiation other than that I don't know
photons and you know neurons
superfluidity of neurons
what's the Sun made of mostly hydrogen I
believe yeah so so if the Sun spits out
some of that stuff right it would be
what is a hydrogen atom what's it made
of
just hydrogen neutrons electrons you
know so in the case of hydrogen is the
simplest atom it's just a proton and an
electron okay
that's it so when we're talking about
stuff coming from the Sun just talking
about streams of protons and electrons
okay there's stuff coming from the Sun
yes and then what does it do
lights up just hey that's they're just
there they're just there yeah they just
happen well I've had a little bit of
luck and I've been trying to shoot them
so I'll put up some of that footage so
you can check it out and you can think
about these particles that must be
streaming in from the Sun colliding with
our upper atmosphere and then exciting
it and so it releases that light when
Indy excites
why don't you come to Alaska and not say
Hawaii or the Caribbean it's the
Northern Lights it isn't well why are
you guys are special I'm not sure
honestly like it's been seen down in
like Mexico and stuff it's like the Reds
have been seen down in Mexico I've
actually seen it in Mexico by my where
my grandmother lives I think it just has
to do with the north northern hemisphere
and how much like little less Sun we get
so you can see it more I'm sure it
happens in the southern hemisphere you
just have a lot of light down there like
their sky is brighter at night well Oh
God
I'm just asking I don't know I don't
know it has to do with magnetic fields
and it the closer you get to the
magnetic fields more the lights you're
able to see then yeah you're right about
the magnetosphere deflects them around
towards the poles and they hit the
atmosphere and they excite the
atmosphere and when it D excites it's
okay giving off that light so I'm here
in Fairbanks with T Neil Davis and thank
you for speaking to me today all right
so we were out looking for the Aurora I
guess one major question that a lot of
people would have is what is it Aurora's
is the result of charged particles
coming down the magnetic long magnetic
field lines which is essentially
vertical here and the those high-speed
particles then strike the gases in the
upper atmosphere and impart energy to
those gases excite the atoms and
molecules fairly shortly thereafter the
atoms and molecules Bieksa tight by
giving off quarter of light and that's
what we see what about the weather you
know last night it seemed like it was a
bit overcast or there were some there
was some cloud up there does that also
hinder
wasn't a thick cloud layer but they just
seemed this bit of a haze yep we had the
moon out oh well then you're really in
trouble yet with the moon out and and a
little haze then it's pretty tough to
see did you have any advice for us how
do we deal with conditions like that I
mean that's able to a bar drink I guess
but I just want to give you an idea cuz
I have a different colored image behind
me just to kind of give you a sense of
scale the Sun right here that would be
the size of the earth
you could put 20 earths or so inside
just that circle where the explosion
occurred